tiens la craie bonsoir à vous je le
disais nous avons plus de l'année à
droite et à gauche auprès des
gouverneurs il ya personne en fait qui
s'opposent à l'ajout d'une équipe à
québec et c'est unanime ici tout le
monde dit que québec c'est une ville de
rock et et puis on l'a vu hier avec le
match entre les canadiens et les
pingouins sans même une équipe
professionnelle
le nouvel amphithéâtre était plein à
craquer alors il n'y a personne selon
nos sources parmi les propriétaires des
équipes qui ne va s'opposer à la
candidature de la ville de québec
malgré tout le président directeur
général pierre dion et l'ancien premier
ministre du canada brian murphy qui est
le président du conseil d'administration
quebecor se sont rendus pour une
rencontre de la dernière chance on peu
dire
c'était la dernière fois que les gens
quebecor pouvait vanté la qualité de
cette candidature
le québec dans l'espoir de revoir leur
vie professionnelle avec les nordiques
nous laissant le directeur pdg de
quebecor pierre dion
j'aime étant entre les mains d' des
gouverneurs de la ligue nationale de
hockey c'est leurs processus et leur
décision mais on à faire en a fait une
cause importante pour le québec
et puis christian gary bettman mais ce
sourire là toujours aussi sibyllin ne
laisse rien paraître
alors lui il dit que la ligue nationale
n'a pas de calendrier que l'expansion ce
n'est pas certain mais nous on a obtenu
des cons les documents confidentiels
patrice de la ligue nationale qui nous
confirme effectivement que la ligue
nationale est en plein processus
d'expansion
écoutez il ya dix-sept groupes 17 villes
dont saskatoon fiat au virginia beach
kansas city houston indianapolis qui ont
présenté les candidatures mais seul
quebecor québec et las vegas ont été
retenus alors lorsque monsieur bettman
nous dit qu'on n'est pas sûr de
l'expansion écoutez je pense qu'il faut
prendre ça avec un grain de sel
mais tout de même il va falloir être
patient parce que le vote doit être fait
auprès des propriétaires de la ligue
nationale ça prend l'appui des trois
quarts 75 % avant qu'on décide
d'admettre de nouveaux clubs de
nouvelles équipes dans la ligue
nationale
je laisse entendre de ce batman un peu
plus tôt aujourd'hui à new york
alors les gouverneurs les propriétaires
qui doivent se rencontrer patrice à
nouveau à pebble beach en californie au
mois de décembre
il serait fort possible qu'ils soient
appelés à se prononcer sur une expansion
et sur la valeur de la candidature de
québec pour que l'équipe est baptisé
proviennent c'est la prochaine étape
merci initialement au revoir merci